we're gonna wrap up today's pre-election
show with something really funny we've
been watching Scottie Nell Hughes a
trump surrogate on CNN this entire
rancid and despicable and
mind-bogglingly stupid presidential
campaign and she really outdid herself a
couple of days ago where she was
criticizing the fact that Hillary
Clinton allowed jay-z to perform at one
of her rallies a hip-hop star jay-z
performed at a Hillary Clinton rally and
she said it's really bad because jay-z
features people throwing Mazel Tov
cocktails in music videos what is a
mazel tov cocktail I have an idea let's
take a look at the video also you look
at jay-z and we talked about this that
night that he might be working on but
one of his main video starts off with a
crowd throwing molotov cocktails at the
police and anti-police message on we
have to play that once more I think
listen that Mazel Tov cocktails I'll see
you look at jay-z and we talked about
this that night that he might be working
on it but one of his main video starts
off with a crowd throwing Molotov
cocktails at the police and this a very
much anti-police message so of course
Mazel Tov is the Hebrew phrase for
congratulations confused with a Molotov
cocktail then she got involved in a
Twitter discussion about the entire
thing and she used the expression of a
but instead instead of 0 y ve y she
spelled it out y e ve y which sounds
more like Spanish than Hebrew I figured
out what she's talking about in those
videos you can see jay-z mixing
Manischewitz wine with a splash of
seltzer and dropping in a matzo ball for
garnish that's a mazel tov cocktail and
that is really offensive to Scottie Nell
Hughes well you're doing much better
damage control and she was able to do I
mean we do a show every day and I'm sure
you know sometimes what comes out is
what you mean but this kind of
demonstrates just no understanding of
the world at all yeah I mean I the other
day I almost talking about the rigged
election almost said the word erection
we almost had to stop the show
Paquette barely keep it together over
there but you managed to do it you
managed it going up there to keep going
uh a mazel tov cocktail this is
hilarious it's just a reminder that even
someone as vile as a trump surrogate as
we've seen Scottie Nell Hughes be can
make just sort of a funny mistake that's
not hugely offensive but just indicative
of her sort of being clueless what's
really off-putting to me about Scottie
Nell Hughes when she shows up on CNN and
she defends the indefensible time and
again and shows up after Trump is
accused of sexually assaulting not one
not two not three not four not five not
six not seven I'll skip it not 17 but
something like 18 women at this point
and she has to show up there an issue
some kind of defense of it that's the
really vile uh and depraved Scottie Nell
Hughes who's up there defending this
stuff Mazel Tov cocktail it's just kind
of funny yeah well we'll give her a pass
on this one I think I mean the elections
almost over I think if at any time we're
gonna give Scottie Nell he's a pass it's
the day before the election for saying
Mazel Tov cocktail